well you know the first year being all
in action consoles we've gone to
extraordinary lengths to bring notary to
get the team on Xbox one ps4 to the fans
and you can move on to the next channel
Hardware everybody wants to see the game
look amazing this was a perfect
opportunity for us to really reenact
this franchise we looked at you know
kind of the fundamentals of gaming you
know visuals gameplay and audio and
presentation we wanted to bring that to
a whole new level at the wrestling team
II haven't seen yet and I wasn't pushing
and one to really just do something
different with how not only our game
plays but I want to change the game for
anybody else that thinks about making
arrests in the game when we started
building 2k15 it was kind of a big
undertaking for us and we really took a
step back and looked at where wrestling
and been in the past and we decided that
we really wanted to bring a lot of what
we have in our visual concepts games to
the table for wrestling our goal was to
shoot for broadcast after NBA 2k14 came
out we knew we had a bar game we pretty
much had to rewrite all our set from
scratch
in order to get the superstars in the
game and scan these guys we had to go
out on the road and go where they go and
these guys are traveling every day and
we'd figure out where they were gonna be
we've had guys in vans for weeks on end
chasing them around from event event
setting up in the backs of stadiums
we've had people fly in and out of
almost every city in North America seems
at one point another we brought a crew
over there and set up shop backstage and
gorilla on post we had them do their
signature expressions we got their flex
maps we got everything by now we've
actually scanned almost everyone on the
roster for the game which is quite an
undertaking well the new face scanning
system is off the chain brother I mean
everything looks like it's really
breathing and it looks like it's the
real deal it's unbelievable
oh those sorts I've never seen no Jen's
face scan system like that before being
in the new video game is you know what
the technology is crazy we're huge
gamers so it was pretty cool to see how
behind the scenes work and how the
machinery the technology goes man
after that we actually get into kind of
the commentary and we've spent a lot of
time on the road with the talent
recording them in side by side sessions
so we get a very authentic commentary
system like they're sitting there
actually ringside night by night let in
the commentary fly now knowing triple
Eight's the way I do I'm not at all
surprised he inserted himself into this
man don't know Triple H you just say you
do you ever had a conversation with a
maverick we hang around we hang out yeah
sure so when the fans pick up the game
for the first time they're gonna be
blown away with the new hardware off the
device the game is shaping up it's
looking beautiful not only what they see
visually what they hear and what their
plan is sad perfect merger of the
aesthetics the most lifelike models that
have ever been in this
it's a completely different game
you